The Joe Rogan experience.
You know,
I was tripped out by man that,
uh,
that underwater treadmill jammy.
Is it an amazing did you want on it?
You gotta do it?
It's sick.
I was,
I was wearing my clothes.
I wasn't gonna jump in there,
but I was like,
what?
Look at,
this is crazy.
This thing.
It's sick man.
You do it.
Yeah.
Did it a few times.
What does it,
is it good for your cardio?
Uh,
it's,
it's low impact on the joints,
right?
So like it's Oh yeah,
you'll,
you'll get it real good cardio.
Really real good cardio push on it because there's jets blowing at you and the,
the treadmills on the bottom.
So you're trying just to not your run it against the water.
Oh Wow.
And so like,
depending on how deep you go,
your arms,
that's all resistance.
Oh,
sure.
You can go just waist level and it's a little bit easier,
but the lower you go,
the harder it is.
Wow.
Good Cardio.
Did you do the zero gravity?
I didn't do any of the things there.
I just looked at him.
That's just keeping the door.
Forrest Griffin,
he gave me the four one one.
Yeah,
they've done a lot of,
when's the last time zero gravity?
It's been awhile maybe.
Or what was the zero gravity?
So there's a treadmill and you put these pants on and then you just slip into
this,
like you zip into it.
Oh,
I did see that.
And then you turn it on and it fills up with this air and then you can run up to
like 10% of your body weight.
So it's just like,
it's another zero gravity,
like the treadmill.
It's not low impact,
low impact,
super low.
And you can go off.
So you're just like tippy toes just like,
oh,
that's so weird.
Yeah.
That's really weird.
Yeah,
they got a lot of cool stuff,
man.
While they're at the forefront of all recovery methods and training methods and
Tricia.
Yeah.
And see what they're doing for us on fight week.
What are they doing?
So this last fight,
um,
they were like,
Hey,
do you want any help?
Do you have your meals prepped or anything like that?
I was like,
no,
I don't.
So I guess for people that are fighting within us for now,
um,
they'll,
they'll prep and make everything for,
for fight week when you're cutting weight and I'll make sure,
wow.
Like you stay in contact with with the guys,
Clinton,
them and they'll uh,
check your weight and then they'll make meals according to you,
like whatever you need,
deliver them to your room.
[inaudible] it was,
it was the best.
And then the recovery afterwards,
they give you these drinks all like Usada approved,
all that stuff.
It's like no problems.
They help,
they help so much with that last weight cut and uh,
and rehydration,
how much do you cut this fight?
I cut
19,
19 pounds and that's a lot.
Usually I usually cut maybe four to seven pounds.
Wow.
The last couple of fights I've Jay,
I would just coast it,
but when I went to Thailand,
there's a lot of sugar and a lot of stuff that I was eating out there cause I
really what it was.
Yeah.
When I was in Bangkok for a long time and it's just a lot of street food,
a lot of fried food and stuff,
and I was just there and I'm like,
I'm going to try everything.
So once I got to Paquette,
they actually have like health food stuff,
Vegan stuff.
They have a lot of tourists there,
especially on the street.
So that the street that Tiger's on all gyms,
it's like five or six crossfit gyms,
maybe 10 restaurants,
the health,
food,
restaurants,
everything.
So I was able to stay on track there.
So just,
I was just back just a few weeks.
Yeah.
But I still may weight,
so that's good.
That's a lot of weight to cut though,
right?
Yeah.
You like to cut like about five or six is that what you mean?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No more than eight.
Like eight is pushing it for me.
So what difference do you feel?
Uh,
the day after I didn't with their rehydration method,
I felt amazing.
Usually cutting that much.
I'd feel a little bit bloated,
low,
heavy sleep,
beer,
all that stuff.
But this,
when do you talking,
did you ever do IB or would you did do ivy?
Yeah,
and when I used to fight in the RFA and,
um,
at one 85,
I used to fight when?
85.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
That's hours.
How much do you got?
Oh,
I used to cut from,
I try to get as close to 200 as possible and then cut.
Wow.
The 15 super skinny,
200,
two terrible.
Oh,
ugh.
Terrible.
I'm struggling to make two oh five nine not struggling,
but like,
it hurts to make two oh five now.
So I couldn't even imagine like,
oh,
it sucked.
[inaudible].